The Joe Rogan Experience how about
cocaine bear no I haven't seen that but
that's a that's a true story I heard
that's a true story yeah Bears lead
anything man that the fact that the bear
ate the coke I wonder what it smelled
like to him wonder why he ate it
did it have did the bear die from a
heart attack I think that was the rumor
I mean it probably overdosed yeah like I
mean if you're eating Coke and you're a
bear bears eat a lot like how much coke
is that like what did that I bet the
Bear's mouth got numb as [__] yeah bro
and I bet every the whole the whole
snout
I bet they enjoy the experience
I bet it I bet it feels good I bet once
you start getting high from that coke
you're like oh this is great and then
you're a bear you're a glutton so you're
just diving in there eating the whole
bag
how did the bear die I'm it happened in
1985. 85. the story the story was 85
you're like man did that really happen
the story was is crazy a plane dumped
dumped the cocaine out bro 75 pounds
they found the Dead bear wow he had two
of them he absorbed only three to four
grams
well that's a lot
the tax yeah what do they think killed
them
oh okay his stomach was literally packed
to the brim with cocaine well he ate
more than three to four grams that seems
like more than three to four grams
only absorbed that much oh he'd only
absorbed that so the rest of it was in
his stomach so he literally ate until
his stomach was packed like a big coke
Rock oh
oh man
because that [__] is probably hard as
[__] cool they probably packed it in
there it's guts if his stomach was
packed to the brim with cocaine oh my
God
that's amazing wow that's amazing what
was it like for that bear just lying
there while your heart is literally
cracking your ribs
have I done that bear could not
understand what the [__] was happening
to him at all he got a literal Rock of
paste in your stomach
and your heart is gone
yeah imagine the heartbeat
[__] what a [__] up last day for a
bear yeah oh and then there was a movie
that was supposed to be funny I heard it
was funny
did you see it Jamie no I haven't seen
it yet yeah I guess I'll watch it I
thought about it I'm gonna wait it's a
great idea but it is when I heard it I
was like nah that can't be a movie so
this is my question that I forgot
earlier was is um does PCP make you
aggressive because ketamine doesn't make
you aggressive right it calms you down
so why do we always associate PCP with
people being wild I think that you they
have to be like sort of it's like
provocation I think they're mellow until
until provoked yeah
I don't want to try it but like I
wouldn't want to be approaching anybody
on PCP no [__] telling them hey you
need that nah and who knows what design
or drugs some [__] chemist is going
to figure out in the future
that takes that to a Next Level I mean
imagine if there was no that's probably
why I bet
uh Dr Edward Domino who participated in
the early testing of PCP documented that
the drug produces an adrenaline release
resulting in a fight or flight reaction
with an increased height uh heart
heartbeat high blood pressure and raised
body temperature
interesting he said that the effects of
the drug can the drug can vary greatly
it can act as depressant stimulant or
hallucinogen depending upon the dosage
type of administration and circumstances
of use on the street PCP is available as
a powder tablet or liquid or in leaf
mixtures it may be swallowed injected
snorted or smoked key factors that
determine whether a PCP user becomes
violent are the user's personality the
physical settings and the external
stimulants like what you're saying like
[__] with them something [__] with
them and then they they go from zero to
a hundred they get triggered yeah it
takes something to trigger them because
I think there's totally in their own
world until someone comes and yeah and
imagine that you're like in a Zone and
then the cops come [__] with you I
mean immediately you're going to be
reactive
they cite the case of West Covina Police
Officer Ken bread who was killed in 1983
by a PCP user who was unfazed by both
mace and Baton blows in a powerful
powerful display of force he uprooted a
sapling
and it's eight foot stake which he
hurled at the officer
then he managed to grab a shotgun out of
the officer's car and kill him holy [__]
dude damn he pulled a tree out of the
ground and threw it at the guy that's
brute [__] strange that that's Hulk
smash strike are we sure it doesn't make
you stronger imagine if we had like MMA
but you could take PCP you can take
whatever drug you want I wonder if
anybody's done weight lifting PR's on it
I wonder it's a good question because
dudes do weird [__] before they do PR's
they drink sometimes guys do shots of uh
whiskey and they do deadlifts just
something I give them whoa [__] give
them that little boost yeah I couldn't
believe that when I heard that that some
people like to do that I don't think
like that I never heard that I've never
heard that that yeah a shot before they
do before they power lift huh could be
just crazy people we should find that
out too I would imagine though like you
feel looser yeah like like some DJs
before they go DJ clubs they'll they'll
have a shot and it makes them loose and
they feel like they Rock the part they
got like the vibe of the party
locked in yeah a shot is a nice way to
get the party started just like well
yeah it gets in there quick little joke
warms the belly
yeah it sounds like people have
definitely tried this
I'm reading a story right now they're
one thing that says it's the most
popular post off of a bodybuilding
Message Board the thread on PCP and
bodybuilding and powerlifting oh wow
this is a 6'5 325 power lifter came in
high on PCP seven percent body fat I'm
going on to see that there are 11 people
Pile in the back of an ambulance to try
to keep them restrained
Jesus Christ dude yeah magic they had to
knock him down with sedatives oh my God
they had to hit him with a dark gun oh
my God power lifting on PCP and just
[__] roid raging around the building
oh man probably PCP and steroids too if
he's that big yeah you got to imagine oh
my God he's on the double dose he's on
the double whammy
that's you know like he he he really
thought that out like okay I know I'm
stronger when I smoke this PCP I'm gonna
go really get my workout all right or
maybe that was his first time and just
sorry guys I didn't know I took a chance
I [__] up I was on PCP lost my mind I
really apologized to everyone
let's hope we'll do it deadlifts what
about shots do people do do that well
I'm looking up deeper discussions on us
it says there's no evidence that it
increases strength but because it just
it's a disassociative do you think that
maybe you can't feel the pain yeah
probably go through it yeah it could be
yeah there's a self-preservation part of
lifting right like if a lift feels too
heavy you put it down maybe if you're on
PCP just [__] it yeah let's go I mean
what's you know well you know hey look
there's parts of the mind that we can't
tap into in a sober state
that give us different abilities right
including strength you know tapping into
something different we're blocked from
it yeah I think so and I think some of
these some of these things like PCP and
others um sort of maybe could unlock
some of that